What's going on?
Happy Holidays!
In today's lesson with Harry Potter
and the Goblet of Fire,
you are going to learn with a scene
in which Ron, Harry and Hermione
attend a Christmas ball — that is
a large formal party
in which people dance and that
in the movie is known as the Yule Ball
Now, "Yule" is an old word for Christmas which is
used still in northern Europe and North America
in some specific context around the holidays.
So this is a really great opportunity for you
to learn all about British culture,
and some differences between
British and American pronunciation
And, if you're new here, every single week we make fun lessons like this one
so that you can understand fast-speaking natives without getting lost, without missing the jokes,
and without subtitles.
Just like this learner, who says that they are amazed
at how fast that their comprehension has improved
by watching our lessons over the last year.
And you're going to learn super fast too,
all you have to do is hit that Subscribe button
and the bell down below
so you don't miss any of our new lessons.
Hey! Do you want to improve your American English pronunciation and comprehension?
Well, then I highly recommend ou
Fluent with Friends course
where every week for 48 weeks you will receive
a fun lesson that follows along
with the first two seasons of the TV series Friends.
Plus, you get 20+ page PDF Power Lessons,
vocabulary memorization software,
access to our Fluency Circle global community,
and so much more.
Plus, you can try it for FREE right now with
our 3-part Masterclass.
What are you waiting for?
Just click up here or down in the description below,
and you can sign up for that right now.
Hey! Are you a muggle who loves the Wizarding World?
Well, then I highly recommend you check out this playlist
where you can learn with all the movies
and the characters from Harry Potter,
and greatly improve your English like magic.
Check that out up here or down in the description below,
after you finish this lesson.
All right! I hope the Yule Ball helped to
get you in the Christmas spirit
and I hope that you'll go and
watch the full Goblet of Fire movie.
Then if you want to take your English to the next level,
then check out one of our other dynamite lessons here.
And now it's time to go beyond the classroom,
and LIVE your English.
Aw Yeah!